Donald Trump has now denied that a North
Korean missile launch happened after
also saying that he's okay with the
missile launch which now he says didn't
happen at least in the way that is being
reported and I've got to take a little
time to set this up when I tell you
about the horrible and erratic
geopolitical behavior of Donald Trump
I'm not telling it to you because it's
funny
I'm not telling it to you to score
political points and frankly there
aren't really political points to be
scored because everybody loses I mean
much of the country gets that this
presidency is a geopolitical foreign
policy disaster and those that don't get
that at this point in time aren't going
to be convinced if I do another story
about the embarrassing ignorant tweet
that Donald Trump posted or yet another
dumb thing that Donald Trump said but
hopefully I've given you some insight on
the show about the importance of the
geopolitical issues that are at stake or
at least some of them and one of those
issues is North Korea sort of in the
context of the Russia china-us
superpower love triangle or whatever you
want to call it and a couple of weeks
ago I explained it in in a little bit of
detail I explained how the United States
has really fallen off the world stage
fault fallen on the world stage fallen
off of it you could say whatever an
allergy or metaphor you want to use in
the two years that Trump has been
president this has happened in ways that
are significantly more far-reaching than
Donald Trump and his administration can
fix right this is something that's going
to take a long time to fix if indeed
it's going to be fixed and we are in the
middle in all of this of a sort of
political realignment geo policy of
politics Germany now by all measures is
the leader of the free world it's not a
literal term don't get mad at me look up
what the term means it's a colloquial
term and Angela Merkel the leader of
Germany has sort of taken the reins from
the United States president who usually
holds that non official title leader of
the free world and in the meantime
what's likely to be the big superpower
fight of the next decade between the
United States and China and Russia he's
really going Russia and China's way in
just about every sense the
is playing right into Russia's hand with
Trump slamming NATO and criticizing our
Western European allies meanwhile the
u.s. relationship with China is
deteriorating in part because of this
trade war that Donald Trump is waging
and losing and meanwhile Russia and
China are getting closer they're making
more industry deals and trade deals and
energy development deals and they're
putting the United States assigned a
side increasingly and in the middle of
this we come to North Korea which we're
talking about today who historically has
had only China as its primary pseudo
ally it's not even really always been an
ally of North Korea China but it's been
an ally in some ways Trump has held two
summits with North Korean dictator Kim
jong-un in both Trump came away
extremely impressed with Kim's sense of
humor his intelligence his negotiation
skills but Trump got nothing out of it
vague promises at the first summit
nothing happened second summit ended
abruptly with no progress but Trump just
seemed smitten
but with Kim jong-un and it was reported
over this past weekend that North Korea
is launching missiles again Japan the
United Nations Security Council Trump's
own national security advisor John
Bolton all saying North Korea has fired
ballistic missiles that violate the
United Nations Security Council
resolutions Trump first tweeted he's
okay with the launch and then later
denied that the launch took place at
least as described if it happened it's
fine but I don't think that it actually
happened even though everybody around me
is telling me that it happened Trump
tweeting first quote North Korea fired
off some small weapons which disturbed
some of my people and others but not me
I have confidence that chairman Kim will
keep his promise to me by the way
chairman what exactly is he chairman of
and also smiled when he called swampman
joe biden a low IQ individual and worse
perhaps that's sending me a signal an
extremely unhinged tweet and instead of
taking the side of our ally Japan of his
own intelligence at
his own national security adviser John
Bolton Trump taking the side of Chairman
Kim and using it as an opportunity to
sort of join with Kim jong-un in
criticizing Joe Biden
so here the position at least initially
is the missile launch happened but Trump
says well it was small weapons and it's
okay
but then Trump in Japan at a joint press
conference with Shinzo Abe a trump just
says oh yeah everybody else is wrong the
launch that I said is fine
really didn't happen Trump saying quote
my people think it could have been a
violation
I view it differently I view it as a man
perhaps he wants to get attention and
perhaps not who knows it doesn't matter
all I know is that there have been no
nuclear tests
there have been no ballistic missiles
going out there have been no long-range
missiles going out he knows that with
nuclear that's never going to happen
only bad can happen he understands he is
a very smart man he gets it understand
that there's the continued ignorant by
Trump when it comes to North Korea but
now it's also wrapped up with an insult
to Japan what while in Japan Trump is
saying that he believes apparently his
own opinion over what Japan believes and
over our own intelligence and over the
United Nations and over our own National
Security Advisor and then it becomes an
issue not just of trumps geopolitical
skill which is close to zero as you can
probably tell but this becomes an issue
about Donald Trump's judgment which
aside from politics and aside from
Trump's position on abortion for example
aside from Trump's positions on issues
when you have a president that's so
significantly lacks in judgment it's
dangerous and that's what I want to talk
about next